[Music]
charter schooling introduced many
important innovations it showed how we
could have school choice inside of
public education how nonprofits could
run public schools how great public
schools can be replicated or expanded
but we've never made full use of one of
the charter school ins most important
contributions contract based
accountability a charter school
negotiates performance contracts with an
authorizer that contract lays out
exactly what the school will accomplish
in exchange the schools then gets
freedom from a wide array of rules
now if the charter school succeeds its
contract will be removed but if it fails
to meet its performance goals the school
will be closed and replaced the new
federal education law encourages States
to create accountability systems
internally
so why not apply contract based
accountability to all public schools in
the city including those run by the
traditional school district this is the
way for all of the pretty schools
charter schools and district schools to
have equal operational freedom and be
held equally accountable to learn more
about my take on charter school
accountability check the links in the
description below also let us know what
other topics you want AI scholars to
cover in 60 seconds